NEWS COVERAGE.
I'M BIANNA GOLODRYGA IN NEW YORK
ALONGSIDE MY COLLEAGUE ANDERSON
COOPER IN LVIV, UKRAINE.
>>> RUSSIAN FORCES ARE SETTING
THEIR SIGHTS ON THE CAPITAL CITY
OF KYIV, ADVANCING TO THE
DOORSTEP OF THAT CITY.
[ SIRENS ]
SIRENS WARNING CIVILIANS IN KYIV
AS AIR STRIKES APPROACHED
OVERNIGHT.
RUSSIAN BOMBS DESTROYING
INFRASTRUCTURE NORTH AND SOUTH
OF THE CITY.
SATELLITE IMAGES SHOW RUSSIAN
ARTILLERY BOMBARDING KYIV.
OFFICIALS SAY THAT THE BULK OF
RUSSIA'S FORCES ARE NOW JUST 15
MILES FROM THE CITY'S CENTER.
>>> FIERCE FIGHTING ALSO UNDER
WAY IN MANY OTHER PARTS OF THE
COUNTRY.
CITIES IN UKRAINE'S EAST AND
SOUTH ARE UNDER A SUSTAINED
RUSSIAN ONSLAUGHT.
AND THE LEADERS OF GERMANY AND
FRANCE CALLING FOR AN IMMEDIATE
CEASE-FIRE THIS MORNING.
UKRAINE CIVILIANS DESPERATE TO
ESCAPE.
TODAY AT LEAST 13 HUMANITARIAN
CORRIDORS ARE OPEN FOR
EVACUATIONS.
THE U.N. SAYS MORE THAN 2 1/2
MILLION UKRAINIANS HAVE FLED THE
COUNTRY.
>>> I WANT TO TURN NOW TO
ANDERSON COOPER ANCHORING OUR
LIVE COVERAGE IN LVIV, THAT'S
WESTERN UKRAINE.
ANDERSON, AS WE ARE WATCHING
RUSSIAN TROOPS ENCROACH UPON
KYIV, IT WAS CHILLING TO HEAR
WHAT WE SAW HAPPEN IN MARIUPOL
IS A PREVIEW OF WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN IN KYIV.
>> YEAH, AND A LOT OF PEOPLE
THROUGHOUT UKRAINE ARE WATCHING
WHAT IS HAPPENING IN MARIUPOL,
THE SIEGE ON THAT CITY, THE
FLATTENING OF NEIGHBORHOODS IN
SOME PARTS OF THAT CITY, A CITY
WHICH IS, ACCORDING TO OFFICIALS
THERE, HAS RUN OUT OF SUPPLIES,
DRINKING WATER.
IT IS REALLY A MISERABLE SCENE.
AGAIN, A PREVIEW OF WHAT MIGHT
HAPPEN IN OTHER CITIES.
LET'S TALK ABOUT IT A LITTLE
BIT.
WE HEARD ABOUT THIS CALL TO
VLADIMIR PUTIN CALLING FOR A
CEASE-FIRE.
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY HAS RECENTLY
SPOKEN ABOUT SOMETHING LIKE
THIS.
>> YEAH, SOME VERY POSITIVE
SIGNS FROM PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY
WHO SAYS WE'VE STOPPED
EXCHANGING ULTIMATUMS WITH THE
RUSSIAN DELEGATION AND WE'VE
STARTED ACTUALLY TALKING.
I MEAN, THAT'S A PRETTY KEY
INDICATION WHEN YOU'RE LOOKING
AT THE LAST SEVERAL DAYS IN
TURKEY WHERE IT SEEMED LIKE
TALKS WERE STALLING, WHERE IT
SEEMED LIKE THERE WAS NO MIDDLE
GROUND BETWEEN THE TWO SIDES.
HERO THE KEY THING, THE SAME
WHICH I THINK WE'RE HEARING FROM
EUROPEAN LEADERS, ANY
NEGOTIATIONS MUST START WITH A
CEASE-FIRE AND THAT'S GOING TO
MEAN THE GUNS HAVE TO FALL
SILENT.
IS THE RUSSIAN MILITARY WILLING
TO DO THAT?
IS PRESIDENT VLADIMIR PUTIN
WILLING TO DO THAT?
ESPECIALLY WHEN WE'RE LOOKING AT
HUMANITARIAN EVACUATIONS EVEN
BEING TARGETS OF ATTACKS.
>> WHEN THE TWO FOREIGN
MINISTERS MET IN TURKEY ON
THURSDAY, I BELIEVE IT WAS,
REALLY NOTHING CAME OUT OF THAT,
AND, IN FACT, IT SEEMED LIKE A
STEP BACK WITH THE RUSSIAN
FOREIGN MINISTER KIND OF GOING
BACK TO TALKING POINTS THAT
VLADIMIR PUTIN HAD BEEN GIVING
EARLY ON ABOUT DE-NAZIIFICATION
AND A NEUTRAL UKRAINE.
>> WHAT DOES PRESIDENT PUTIN
WANT OUT OF THIS?
IT'S AN OFFENSIVE THAT ASTOUNDED
ALL OF US.
ONE OF THE TOWNS ATTACKED
YESTERDAY IS 70 MILES FROM THE
BORDER OF POLAND.
IT'S AN OFFENSIVE THAT IS
REACHED FAR INTO UKRAINE, THAT,
OF COURSE, HAS ITS CAPITAL,
KYIV, UNDER MAJOR CONCERN, UNDER
INTENSE ATTACK.
SO WHAT IS THE END GOAL HERE FOR
PRESIDENT PUTIN?
WHAT IS ENOUGH TO END THIS?
WE KNOW FROM PRESIDENT
ZELENSKYY'S SIDE WHAT HE'S
OFFERED, HIS OLIVE BRANCH IS THE
PROMISE THAT UKRAINE WOULD
REMAIN A NEUTRAL COUNTRY, THAT
IT WOULD NOT JOIN NATO, WHICH IS
NOT ON THE TABLE ANYWAYS.
BUT THERE'S GOING TO HAVE TO BE
SOME BACK AND FORTH.
THE RUSSIAN PRESIDENT DOES HAVE
A STRATEGIC GOAL HERE, AND THAT
IS ACCESS TO A WARM WATER PORT.
WHAT DOES THAT ACCESS LOOK LIKE
TERRITORIALLY WHEN YOU'RE
LOOKING AT THE EAST OF THE
COUNTRY?
>> AND WHETHER THAT'S ACCEPTABLE
TO UKRAINIANS AT ALL.
IT'S OBVIOUSLY ONE OF THE MAJOR
ISSUES.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>>> WE'RE WITNESSING A BRUTAL
ONSLAUGHT OF CITIES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY AND THAT INCLUDES AREAS
THAT HAD BEEN LARGELY SPARED
FROM THE BLOODSHED THUS FAR.
CNN'S MATTHEW CHANCE HAS MORE.
>> Reporter: THIS IS A NEW FRONT
IN RUSSIA'S UKRAINIAN WAR.
EMERGENCY WORKERS BATTLING
FLAMES CAUSED BY AIR STRIKES ON
THE CENTRAL CITY OF DNIPRO.
AN APARTMENT BUILDING, A
KINDERGARTEN AND A TWO-STORY
SHOE FACTOR WY WERE TARGETED.
70 MILES FROM POLAND, A
STRATEGIC AIRFIELD ALSO CAME
UNDER ATTACK.
WITH THE INVASION IN ITS THIRD
WEEK, RUSSIA APPEARS TO BE
WIDENING ITS ASSAULT.
THERE ARE CONCERNS OF ESCALATION
TOO.
RUSSIAN STATE TELEVISION HAS
BEEN BROADCASTING THESE IMAGES,
THE FIGHTERS FROM SYRIA SET TO
BE VOLUNTEERING TO JOIN THE
FIGHT ON RUSSIA'S SIDE.
THE KREMLIN BACKS THE SYRIAN
REGIME AND THE SCENES APPEARED
SHORTLY AFTER PUTIN TOLD HIS
SECURITY COUNCIL THAT FOREIGN
FIGHTERS SHOULD BE INVITED TO
JOIN IN.
>> Translator: IF YOU SEE PEOPLE
WHO WANT WITHOUT PAYMENT TO COME
AND HELP PEOPLE LIVING IN
DONBAS, WELL, WE NEED TO MEET
THEIR EFFORTS AND HELP THEM TO
REACH THE COMBAT ZONE.
>> Reporter: THESE ARE THUGS
FROM SYRIA, SAID PRESIDENT
ZELENSKYY OF UKRAINE, THE
COUNTRY DESTROYED IN THE SAME
WAY THE OCCUPIERS ARE DESTROYING
US, HE SAID.
LATER AT A KREMLIN MEETING WITH
HIS BELARUSIAN ALLY, PRESIDENT
PUTIN STUCK AN UPBEAT FORM
SAYING HE HAD BEEN TOLD OF
POSITIVE SHIFTS IN RECENT TALKS
WITH UKRAINE.
THEY DON'T SEEM TO BE DIVERTING
RUSSIA FROM ITS INVASION COURSE.
NEW SATELLITE IMAGES SUGGEST A
MASSIVE RUSSIAN MILITARY COLUMN
NORTH OF KYIV HAS NOW DISPERSED
WITH SOME ELEMENTS REPOSITIONED
INTO FORESTS AND COUNTRYSIDE
AROUND THE CAPITAL.
AND THESE ARE THE LATEST IMAGES
FROM THE BESIEGED UKRAINIAN TOWN
OF VOLNOVAKHA, IN THE COUNTRY'S
SOUTHEAST.
RUSSIAN TROOPS MOVING THROUGH
THE STREETS WHICH ARE NOW
REPORTED TO BE UNDER THEIR FULL
CONTROL.
BIT BY BIT, UKRAINE, IT SEEMS,
IS BEING OVERRUN.
MATT CHANCE, CNN, KYIV.
>>> WITH US NOW IS DEPUTY
MAJORITY LEADER IN UKRAINE'S
PARLIAMENT.
SHE IS IN WESTERN UKRAINE.
THANKS SO MUCH FOR BEING WITH
US.
RUSSIAN FORCES HAVE BEEN
WIDENING THEIR STRIKES NOW TO
WESTERN UKRAINE, WITH BOMBS AND
MISSILES.
WHY DO YOU THINK THEY HAVE HIT
THE AIRFIELD IN LUTSK?
>> THEY ARE TRYING TO SHELL THE
INFRASTRUCTURE WHILE AIR RELATED
TO INFRASTRUCTURE.
SO UKRAINE HAS LESS
INFRASTRUCTURE TO FIGHT BACK.
BUT WE STILL HAVE AIRPORTS AND
WE CAN USE PLANES AND WE
DESPERATELY NEED MORE MILITARY
PLANES TO ACTUALLY FIGHT BACK
WITH -- FIGHT BACK WITH RUSSIANS
IN AIR.
AND WE HOPE THAT WE WILL RECEIVE
MORE MILITARY AID, INCLUDING AIR
DEFENSE, ANTIMISSILE AND
MILITARY PLANE TO PROTECT OUR
PEOPLE.
I SHOULD SAY THAT ACTUALLY
RUSSIAN TROOPS DID NOT RECEIVE
ANY MAJOR MILITARY SUCCESSES AND
THAT'S WHY THEY HAVE STARTED A
REAL TERROR IN THE LAND OF
UKRAINE.
THEY HAVE STARTED TO KILL
INNOCENT CIVILIANS AND TO SHELL
JUST NEIGHBORHOODS --
RESIDENTIAL NEIGHBORHOODS,
HOSPITALS, KINDERGARTENS AND
SCHOOL MASSIVELY.
WHAT THEY ARE DOING IN MARIUPOL
IS A CRIME AGAINST HUMANITY.
ALSO, YOU MENTIONED PREVIOUSLY
IN YOUR PROGRAM THAT WE HAVE
MANAGED TO NEGOTIATE THE
HUMANITARIAN CORRIDORS.
THAT'S TRUE.
IT HAPPENED A WEEK AGO.
BUT WE SEE THAT IN THE NUMBER OF
CITIES AROUND KYIV AND ALSO IN
THE EAST OF UKRAINE, WE STILL
CAN'T -- WE STILL CAN'T LET
PEOPLE OUT OF THIS CITY.
WE CAN'T HELP THEM TO --
THEMSELVES BECAUSE RUSSIAN
TROOPS ARE SHOOTING AT INNOCENT
CIVILIANS.
THEY ARE SHOOTING AT FAMILIES
WITH CHILDREN IN THEIR ARMS.
IN MARIUPOL A COUPLE DAYS AGO,
RUSSIANS HAVE SHOOTED AT
MATERNITY HOUSE AND THESE ARE
ALL THE HORRIBLE THINGS THAT
UKRAINIAN CIVILIANS AND
UKRAINIAN CITIES ARE GOING
THROUGH.
>> YEAH.
LET ME ASK YOU, PRESIDENT
ZELENSKYY YESTERDAY IN A PRESS
CONFERENCE TALKED ABOUT THE NEED
FOR A CEASE-FIRE BEFORE ANY
TALKS CAN REALLY TAKE PLACE,
BEFORE ANY REAL NEGOTIATIONS CAN
TAKE PLACE.
DO YOU SEE ANY SIGNS FROM THE
RUSSIAN FEDERATION -- PRESIDENT
ZELENSKYY IN THAT PRESS
CONFERENCE SAID HE WAS PLEASED
WITH SOME OF THE SIGNALS COMING
FROM THE RUSSIAN FEDERATION, BUT
ARE YOU AT ALL HOPEFUL THAT
RUSSIA WOULD AGREE TO A
CEASE-FIRE IN ORDER TO CONDUCT
SERIOUS TALKS?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, HOPE -- WE DO
HOPE FOR THE BETTER.
BUT CURRENTLY, THE RUSSIANS DO
NOT FOLLOW THEIR OWN AGREEMENTS.
SO THE PROMISE TO UKRAINIAN SIDE
THAT THEY WILL LET CIVILIANS TO
EVACUATE THEMSELVES AND THEY
DON'T.
THEY PROMISE THAT THEY WILL LET
SOME FOOD AND WATER IN THE
CITIES, BUT THEY DON'T.
IN MARIUPOL, A NUMBER OF PEOPLE,
INCLUDING CHILDREN, HAVE DIED